how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being if you take a
thought and a feeling the only one
that's called an attitude yes there's a
good thoughts with a series of Good
Feelings you say I have a good attitude
today your series of negative thoughts
that are connected to a series of
negative feelings you seem a bad
attitude today so attitudes are just
shortened states of being good attitude
in the morning bad attitude in the
afternoon if you take an attitude and
attitude imagine you keep those up any
string attitudes together you create
what's called a belief but a belief is
just an extended state of being so if
you keep thinking the same thought you
keep hard wiring in the brain you keep
feeling the same feeling you keep
conditioning in your body the redundancy
of that cycle over and over again
conditions the body to subconsciously
become the mind of that belief and all
beliefs or subconscious states of being
perceptions are just such extended
states of being that we're unconscious
and so then we edit out reality in fact
most people don't see things the way
they are they see things the way they
are right and people are always filling
in reality unconsciously based on their
memory hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because of my first
business I struggled to stay afloat I
quit my business partner and the thing
that kept me going was studying the
stories of famous entrepreneurs and
seeing how they struggled and seeing
what they had to overcome and listen to
their wisdom motivation gave me the
Courage the strength the belief to go
one more day and see my business through
and in all honesty I still need the
inspiration wisdom motivation today for
my business too so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to
attract things to us faster
Joy
they could be married to a person for 40
years and they don't see the person they
see the memory of the person right and
there's research to prove this okay so
how do we change the belief of
perception about ourself for our lives
okay we've studied this
okay let's just say that lack is
ingrained in there you got the story
lived on the streets you lost everything
you got betrayed your business partner
took everything took your wife took you
got the story in the half okay okay you
gotta start telling the new story of the
future right you got to believe in that
future more than you have to believe in
the past so how do you do that you only
believe in the past when you feel the
emotions of the past
the only time you're going to believe in
the future is when you feel the emotions
the future right okay so in order for us
to change a belief or perception about
ourself and our lives
we have to make a decision with such
firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardwired
programs in your brain and the emotional
conditioning in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you remember
the decision okay so then how do we down
regulate that old belief if the trauma
created emotional quotient of sex
or seven then your decision to change
your beliefs got to be a nine right and
you've got to come out of your resting
state and that moment has to Define you
you could say I know exactly where I was
the time and day it was who I was with
when I made my mind up to change right
because you created a long-term memory
long-term memories are created with some
strong emotion right but at the
amplitude of that emotion is greater
than the Betrayal Boom the body starts
responding to the mind and
you're actually giving your body a taste
of the future emotionally so you brand
your voice possible no your body's
actually getting the taste of that
future event experiencing the future now
big explosion on the quantum field big
explosion so the side effect of that
is if you combine that clear intention
with that elevated emotion you're
basically remembering your future and it
looks no different than remembering your
past think neurologically within the
circuits of that memory and feel within
the emotions of that new belief and
watch your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change and when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lack or lack of Separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for us
to become abundant
we have to overcome the old personality
rule number two adopt a money magnet
mindset with Jack Canfield if you're not
paying attention to how much you spend
every month you may quickly find
yourself in debt and one of the worst
things about debt is the stress it puts
on you it robs you of your peace of mind
and reduces your overall quality of life
but it doesn't need to be this way no
matter what your Current financial
situation is you can develop a money
magnet mindset that will Empower you to
get out of debt and create a healthy
financial future for yourself and your
family now my first money magnet tip is
to become aware of your negative and
limiting beliefs about money and replace
them with new beliefs one of the most
effective ways to do this is to
reprogram the subconscious mind with
affirmations
now affirmations are simply positive
statements that you repeat over and over
to yourself on a daily basis for at
least 30 days until they are installed
permanently into the subconscious
now here are some examples of negative
and limiting money beliefs
money doesn't grow on trees there's not
enough money to go around
you have to have money to make money
you can't get rich during a recession
money is the root of all evil
money can't buy happiness
I can't make a lot of money doing what I
love to do
you have to work too hard to make money
people resent me if I have a lot of
money
no matter what I do I'm always in debt
so one of the affirmations that are the
opposite of these beliefs
think about these I live in an abundant
universe and money always comes to me
easily and effortlessly
there is always enough money for
everything I need and want
I am always finding new ways to make
more money
keep getting wealthier no matter what
the economy is doing
money is the root of all good things
the more money I have the happier I
become
the more I do what I love the more money
flows into my life
I am a magnet for success and good
fortune
the more money I have the more good I
can do in the world
no matter what I do money keeps pouring
into my life
I rejoice in the success of others and
they rejoice in mine
every day in every way my wealth is
increasing
whenever I spend or give away money it
comes back to me multiply
I love money and money loves me I am a
powerful money magnet
so I encourage you to watch this again
and write those down and then repeat
them every day for 30 days
now here's my second tip for becoming a
money magnet practice gratitude for what
you already have
most people spend most of their time
focusing on talking about and obsessing
over what they don't have rather than
focusing on celebrating and expressing
gratitude for what they do have
and the result of that is it puts you
into a state of consciousness of lack
focusing on and complaining about what
you don't have put you into a lower
state of vibration which results in
continuing to attract the same lack of
abundance that you're complaining about
so by focusing on what you do have and
consciously being grateful for it you
put yourself into a higher vibration and
you end up attracting more things to be
grateful for
this is how the Law of Attraction works
so to put this into practice I recommend
two practices first take a few minutes
every morning to Simply write down what
you're grateful for there's so many
things to be grateful for your house
your apartment your friends and family
your car your motorcycle your bicycle
the public transportation system the
clean water that comes out of your
faucet
did you know there are millions of
people in the world who have to walk
more than an hour to get to a source of
water and often it's not even the
cleanest of water
you know be grateful for your
refrigerator electricity and electric
lights your television your cell phone
your computer the internet the fact that
we have Wikipedia Uber Lyft Airbnb
credit card sunrises and sunsets the
smell of a rose the fact that you have a
sense of smell at all and so on life
really is quite miraculous
so appreciate it now the other practice
is to express real heartfelt
appreciation to at least five people a
day
your partner if you're in a relationship
your children one of your parents a
neighbor your co-workers your employees
the bus driver the person at the grocery
store check out Connor your waiter or
waitress the UPS driver even the TSA
worker at the airport the street
musician the Barista who makes your
coffee your clients and customers how
about the kid who cuts your grass your
babysitter your housekeeper and so on
I'm talking about really stopping for a
minute looking them in the eye and
sharing something deeper than a simple
thank you letting them know what exactly
it is that you appreciate
for example I just want you to know how
much I appreciate you for getting up
every morning it was what must be 5 a.m
to be here to open your coffee shop and
do all the things that you have to do to
get ready so I can get here at 7am and
get a great cup of coffee and for the
time you've invested in learning how to
pull a way above average shot of
espresso
and if you can't do it in person send a
note a card a letter or an email with
the same level of appreciation
my third tip to become a money magnet
also has two parts the first is to
always carry a 100 dollar bill or it's
equivalent wherever you live like Euros
in Europe
in your pocket your wallet or your purse
now this way you can never say I don't
have any money secondly every time you
take money out of your pocket or you go
into your wall or your purse you'll see
that hundred dollar bill and you'll
think I am abundant you are never broke
you always know that in an emergency you
can always afford to buy a meal or take
a taxi home and if you do ever spend it
immediately replace it now as simple as
this seems it has a huge psychological
effect on your abundance mindset
part of this tip is to write yourself a
check for the amount of money you would
like to earn every year and carry it
with you as well now you can download
one from the internet print out the
blank chat for this purpose and then
fill in whatever amount you want it
could be for a hundred thousand dollars
or a million dollars or in the case of
Jim Carrey he wrote himself a check for
10 million dollars now I'm sure you know
Jim Carrey he's a famous actor in
Hollywood but that wasn't always the
case before I became well known he was
broke and struggling to make ends meet
he loved acting and he was determined to
make money from it so on the check he
wrote to himself he wrote the exact
amount of money he wanted to make 10
million dollars and then he wrote that
it was for acting services rendered he
didn't write a date on that check but he
fully believed that he'd get the money
later when his father died he decided to
put the check in the urn that contained
his father's ashes and he kept on
believing and several years later just
before Thanksgiving in 1995 he was
offered 10 million dollars to play a
lead role in the movie Dumb and Dumber
that's how it worked you probably heard
me tell a similar story in the movie in
the book The Secret about how I first
manifested a 100 000 income and later a
million dollar royalty check for the
first Chicken Soup for the Soul book
now here's my fourth tip for becoming a
money magnet it's spend time hanging out
with people who have more money than you
and also spend time hanging out in
places that represent wealth and
abundance let's look at each of these
things in more depth first hanging out
with people who are wealthier who make
more money than you do you may remember
that I teach you are the average of the
10 people you spend the most time with
now when you spend time with people who
are living in abundance over time their
thought processes their beliefs their
habits and their behaviors will rub off
on you you learn about wealth just by
being in their presence
John azeraf who was one of the featured
teachers in the movie The Secret came
from very humble beginnings he did not
go to college but he also became a very
successful multi-millionaire now he told
me that it all started when he landed a
job in a gym at the Jewish Community
Center across the street from his
apartment in Montreal
in addition to earning 1.65 an hour he
received access to the Men's Health Club
and John said that he got his Early
Education and business in the men's
sauna every night after work he would
sit in the steamy hot room listening to
successful businessmen tell their Tales
of success and failure all the while
learning important business principles
every night he was in the presence of
men from all walks of life who had
become successful and freely shared
their wisdom and experience with them
now in addition to hanging out with
successful people place yourself in the
places and conditions that successful
people hang out in
program your unconscious for success by
going to the showrooms of expensive cars
and sitting in those cars even test
driving them Mercedes Lexus Tesla BMW
Porsche have the sales person take a
picture with your cell phone if you're
sitting in the car looking out through
the passenger window or standing next to
the car and tell him or her that you'll
be back to buy that car soon
go sit in the lobby bar at the Ritz
Carlton or a Four Season Hotel go look
at expensive jewelry or watches at a
jewelry store try on a Rolex a Cartier a
tag hair
fatigue Philippe or Breitling watch
go to open houses are the most expensive
homes for sale in your community or to a
neighboring Community take your time
looking around and imagining living
there go to your local Boutique clothing
stores and try on some expensive clothes
get used to how you look in them rule
number three is stay focused with Rhonda
Byrne we always have to take action for
what we want or can we manifest without
action because a few of the things I've
manifested like changing the venue of my
school picnic I did without action and
forgetting a chocolate cake I randomly
went to a market on my Grandpa bought it
so I wanted to say this and I talk about
it in the secret and we have been so
orientated toward action
we that was one of the beliefs remember
that I said that we have to do something
to get something because you can't get
anything for nothing
so you definitely don't have to take
action
that is a world belief it really is it's
a world belief
um
so
I just want you to know that your focus
of what you want is more more is
stronger and more powerful than any
action you could ever take if you stay
focused for one minute on something you
want honestly it's like 10 years of
action so understand the incredible
mental power that you have to bring
about what you want in the world every
single thing you do in life
is following a thought you can't do
anything without having the thought
first of all to do it and so thought
always precedes everything else and so
and so if
and so in a nutshell
thought is more powerful than any action
you can ever take
and that should help you in your life to
just remember that also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is activate the power
within you with Bruce Lipton the body
provides us with Sensations
pain love joy happiness anger whatever
it comes from this mechanism it's a
mechanism the the eyes take in light but
they don't they don't see light back
here in the brain they say energy
vibrations
sound comes in my ears I don't hear the
sound I hear the vibrations taste that's
a vibration it's a chemical vibration it
almost says oh my God this is a
transducer it takes life experiences in
a body that gives us vision and smell
and taste and touch and pain and love
and joy and I say and this is sent back
to our source so we came here to have
life experiences and I go at that moment
of Awakening I said oh crap here's a
major difference between men and women
men are not allowed to have these
sensory experiences and I'll give you a
reason but women are so women are
sensitive they and that's a way of life
for them they're sensitive and then they
go about but men are so insensitive I go
that was a program
we were programmed to be insensitive for
a very simple reason you cannot be a
soldier if you're sensitive
you can't kill somebody if you're
sensitive so men have been knowingly
programmed to lose sensitivity so they
can be used to do those jobs like
killing somebody else and I go oh my God
then I miss the reason for being on this
planet I missed the feeling of what is
love all about you know what are these
senses of joy and happiness I'm not
allowed to experience them as a guy
because uh that interferes with the
soldier job I go I'm wasting my life and
that was a wake-up call I said well damn
it go out and taste it and touch it and
feel and smell it and do whatever you
want and if it's really good do it again
and if it didn't work out so good then
don't do that one again you came here to
have these experiences why do you want
to waste your life having all the
negative fear anxiety all those problems
it was a choice
it was consciousness
but we didn't know that because we were
programmed to be victim
and a victim has no power
and as long as you believe you're a
victim then you manifest victim
and this is why I'm so uh honored to be
with you Jeff because you're
experiencing this you know this stuff
you're trying to get this message out to
the other people why to wake us all up
because we came here to manifest heaven
on Earth like Falling in Love
and I go now what about all this war and
pestilence and plague and and all these
things I go oh that's a manifestation
and we're manifesting it
you can live in this world without even
being involved with all those things you
just have to change who you are and what
you are and what you want conscious mind
versus programs subconscious mind
and when you understand this you become
empowered when I say empowered to do
what I say create heaven on Earth and
then people think oh you die and go to
heaven I go boy is that a big mistake
because you're going to get to the
Pearly Gates Saint Peter's going to be
there and he says well
how was your experience on Heaven he
said what do you mean he said you were
on earth right that's Heaven why that's
where you came to create what did you
create I go oh
I don't want to wait to the end man
my my mother remarried when she was
relatively older and she married this
guy who was I said curmudgeony guy he
was not really a happy guy or anything
he lived to be like 95 96 or something
he had cancer my mother took care of him
at home the last week of his life
essentially wasn't there he was just
comatose more or less in the bed and
then two days before he died he all of a
sudden his eyes opened up he was there
and he looked at my mother and he said I
didn't have any fun
and all of a sudden I just said holy
crap he's gonna die in two days and he
woke up today he didn't have any fun I
said that's not me babe because when I
finish it's going to be that was great
let's do it again rule number five is
honor the difficulties with Gabby
Bernstein and we all have that truth
that capacity that magnitude within us
and we all have unique ways in which we
will express it
but we may be blocking it
and right now I want you to just notice
one of the biggest blocks is the victim
mentality of I can't get out of this and
every single person in this room may or
may not maybe a few of you don't but
most of us in this room may be living
right now in a way where you're thinking
well how am I going to get over this
part of my life or how could I transcend
that or how can I get there I
interviewed a lot of you guys yesterday
in the elevators in the lobby
I talked you didn't realize it but I was
interviewing you
and I got really clear about what's up
it's the belief system that's lacking
that we all need to transcend and I hope
that this moment in time can be a
Quantum shift for you
I believe that if you want that
that this moment in time with me
can be a Quantum shift for you
I want to honor
the difficult stuff first though
because as the Beautiful
Sufi poet Rumi said
the wound is the place where the light
enters you
take a look at the wounds in your life
maybe you could start to see that loss
of that job as your opportunity to
finally step into your entrepreneurial
dream
or you could see that divorce as an
opportunity for you to get closer to
your truth
heal yourself love yourself more than
you ever could have imagined
or you can see that loss of a loved one
as an opportunity to get closer to a
spiritual connection of your own
understanding
and when we decide to see those
difficult moments in our life with that
vision of belief and Hope and Faith that
there could be something better that's
what everything opens up that's when
invisible doors open for us that's when
when the universe starts to conspire
We All In This Moment have something
that we've been suffering from but we
have two choices of how we're going to
see it we can see it through the lens of
fear we can see it through the lens of
Hope and optimism and a belief system
beyond our wildest dreams
we can
we can and rule number six the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
overcome your money blocks with Marissa
peer and here's the thing about the mind
it's really important to understand
every thought you think every word you
say is a blueprint that you must move
towards because one of the rules of the
mind is that your body and mind act in a
way that matches
up to your thinking you act in a way
that is utterly consistent with how you
define yourself and when you say things
like I don't know where the money's
coming from I don't like to ask for
money because spiritual people shouldn't
ask for money good people don't want
money when you say those things those
throwaway things oh money slips through
my fingers I can never keep money you
are making a blueprint and you are
making yourself work to meet that
blueprint and when you know that you
have to meet a better blueprint don't
talk about bananas and apples talk about
investing and I know this to be true
because I've worked with many many
lottery winners whose blueprint was well
we never had money my father got paid on
Friday by Thursday there was no money
they won the lottery I worked with one
guy and he was earning three hundred
dollars a week he won 15 million dollars
you know what he did what he always did
he spent it until it gone that was his
pattern he comes in on a Friday I spend
spend spend and by following Friday it's
gone within three years he was utterly
broke back in the cookery fed and he
said something interesting I prefer it I
didn't know who my friends were that
wasn't true but he made that true and
I've worked with a lot of rock stars who
also were earning 4 million a year for
five years and when their career ended
they had nothing because they never had
parents who invested and so I want you
to think just for a minute of some of
the thoughts I know you will have heard
about money and if you're brave shout
them out they're all the same how many
people heard money doesn't grow on trees
I can't find the money who had that you
don't find money you earn it I don't
know where the money's coming from money
slips through my fingers the more money
I have the more it goes
say that again
you think I'm made of money what else
who do you think you are we can't afford
that who do you think you are you take
your kids or go pick a piece of candy
they come out the big box you go who do
you think you are we haven't got the
money for that and the kid thinks oh I
shouldn't ask for anything it upsets
people if I ask for money and then years
down the line what happens is they can't
ask for money
so shout out a few more very quickly
do you know what the eye of a needle is
it's actually the doors to a walled City
and at night they shut the top one and
left the bottom one open for the camels
to come through on their knees to make
sure they were safe and that was true
but it had nothing to do with money but
these things get passed down and we
think that's true what else any more
beliefs crazy weird beliefs go ahead
investing is difficult keeping money is
difficult who hears it slips through my
fingers I don't know where the money
goes who says of course you know where
it goes you set up an account what comes
in what goes out and we delude ourselves
when I was small
um I was also really undersized so it's
probably one of the reasons I lift
weights I was always every baseball
picture on the kid holding a sign in the
front right so I was small and skinny uh
they used to tease me Eddie's spaghetti
you know and I'd get bullied at school
and I never retaliated so I had that
mixed with shyness mixed with chaos in
my home which many people can relate to
and I gotta tell you that the shift for
me Sports was good for me because it
gave me an out that I finally found
something that I was pretty good at I
think the biggest shift in our lives the
things that makes us the happiest is
that when somebody helps us identify our
natural giftedness
and when I was a little boy I got a
little bit older they pointed out my
speed
so it wasn't my lack of size I was fast
I was the fast kid right I always wanted
to be fast kid and I got confidence in
baseball doing that when I got into
business I said you know you're intense
when someone points out a gift about you
that you also kind of intuitively know
to be true
they're linked to him you're intense
you're passionate you won't get out work
you're Relentless I want I am those
things and when someone linked those
gifts to me winning now I believed I
could win that's the other way to change
identity is when someone can link your
giftedness to the victory you'll believe
it not like you're great that's General
that's [ __ ] right but it's something
you know specific like for you right now
you wouldn't brag about there's a few
things you know you know what I am good
at these things right I've always been
good at these things it's natural for me
and when someone links that to you
winning like for you for example you're
an unbelievable interviewer you have
this General you you don't need to be
the smartest person in the room because
you probably are most of the time and so
there's a confidence no there's a
confidence that allows you to be present
when you interview me and just listen
that's different than anyone who's
interviewed me before and so that's a
natural giftedness for you which is why
there's a part of you that kind of knows
I am pretty you wouldn't say it but I am
pretty good at this this is a good
program and so the way we change our
identity the way I changed mine was by
getting in touch with what some of my
natural gifts were and and using them in
my career using them in my life that
shifted the weight right off of me
because the weight was I suck I'm shy
I'm small I have a screwed up family
that's the weight right the lifting off
of the weight is these are some gifts
God gave me or the universe gave me or
that at least I know I have and I can
spend my life using these gifts now I've
got hope now my identity is changing now
my life takes a different direction the
beautiful thing about monk life is half
the day is self and half the day is
service that's how you're taught to live
okay so the morning hours are for you to
fill yourself it's almost like putting
on mental emotional and physical armor
like that's what a morning routine is
odd days are tiring our days are busy
our days are draining well guess what if
you didn't put your armor on in the
morning and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you how
many wounds are you going to come home
with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded
I come back home feeling wounded
sometimes but guess what if you put your
armor on in the morning a warrior would
never go out onto a Battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are warriors in one sense and so
without wearing that so for me a morning
routine is putting on emotional armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut you're protected and I
know that when my morning routine is at
its best I feel protected whereas when
my morning routine is weakened I feel
weak and so for me the morning routine
as I get strategic about it there's two
principles you have to know
location has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now holds that
energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and I'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when I meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
South India it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years and so when
you find a space in your home and even
if you've got like I lived in a 500
square foot apartment in New York four
years ago and I just had a tiny Corner
which I dedicated to my sacred practices
so if you you don't have to have a big
home to do this you don't have to be
wealthy to do this you can find just a
corner in your home that you dedicate as
your meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing time has memory and this is
something that people underestimate when
you do something at the same time every
day
you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle to work out at different times
every day it's why we struggle like why
do we feel hungry at the same time every
day generally we feel hungry at the same
time most people if you've got regulated
diet you will feel hungry you'll feel
tired at the same time every day you
will look towards that coke can or that
sugar or that chocolate bar at the same
time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what I recommend to people
well is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and I call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e T stands
for thankfulness there needs to be even
if it's five minutes five minutes of
thankfulness of gratitude every single
morning and that has to be gratitude
that's specific it can't be gratitude
that's generic so generic gratitude is
something that anyone could be grateful
for oh I'm grateful for the sky I'm
grateful for air I'm grateful for water
that's cool but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude is I'm grateful for
the fact that I have someone calling me
this morning I'm grateful for the fact
that I can still call my parents I'm
grateful for the fact that I have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact I'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is Insight I think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which I
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcast books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table I
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and I
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you pick up one line it will impact
you and it'll speak to you so Insight
you need Insight every day m is
meditation and I believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did Beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice I give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than I can I exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise I think
um we're living in such an amazing time
right now I mean if you are not being
challenged in some way in your life
you're not alive
and all of this is an initiation
and I don't believe that you have to go
to any school of ancient wisdom perched
in the Himalayas
are for information or training any
longer if you see your life
as the school as the initiation then you
can no longer be a victim to your life
you're going to have to meet the
challenges in your life from a greater
level of Mind greater than the mind that
created it and so there have been plenty
of peer-reviewed articles on the power
of Peace Gathering projects that lower
crime that lower trauma incidences of of
uh death and economic growth it's all
related to what's happening right now
for us
and it's not enough though for us to
just focus on peace and expect the World
to Change because in the peace Gathering
projects when the event was over a lot
of the crime and violence returned back
to its ceiling level again
it's more important for us
not only to embody that peace and feel
it but then to demonstrate it
and when we begin to demonstrate it I
think we give people permission to do
the same
that means that we can't be preaching
peace and then be stuck in traffic and
you know flipping people off or you know
or arguing with your co-worker you don't
get to stand up for peace if you have
conflict in your life so when we start I
believe start that self-contemplative
process of looking within and instead of
judging someone or something look to see
if there's an aspect of ourselves within
that person or when that situation that
we may need to change and if we're all
doing that at the same time something
greater greater Consciousness is going
to emerge and so I believe that it
should never be about a person
it should be about principles and when
we stand up for principles that creates
Community because you could be one
belief or another belief but if you're
sharing the same principles which are
joy and freedom and cooperation and
connection that's what builds
communities
so then
everything in our world right now is
reminding us of Separation whether it's
War whether it's violence whether it's
political deceit whether it's Prejudice
all of those things cause us to live by
those stress hormones and when we're
living in that state of survival we're
not trusting and we become more selfish
so then starting our day asking
ourselves what would be the greatest
expression of myself I'd like to present
to the world
and then making the choice to not get up
until we are that person I think that
begins to demonstrate greatness
and when there is adversity and when
there are challenges in our life the
question of course becomes how do we
become Supernatural
and that means we're going to have to do
what feels unnatural at first when
everybody else is in poverty and lack
that's the time to give
when everybody else is in fear and
vigilance that's the time to show
courage
when people are angry and hating and
Prejudiced that's the time to show
compassion people are competing to rush
to get to the top that's the time to
change your energy and draw the
experience to you
and if you keep doing what's unnatural
over and over again sooner or later
you're going to become Supernatural when
we talk about
or think about the law of attraction
before we even consider that law and
several other corollary laws when we
talk about everything is energy what
does that really mean
right like what does that really mean
and when you think about you know we use
telescopes to look into outer space into
the cosmos and we use microscopes to
look deeper into material things until
it all disappears anyway right we can
see electrons and protons and muons and
quarks and leptons the Very fundamental
building blocks of nature of our body of
plants of the ocean of everything in the
known Cosmos and it appears
that everything is vibrating if you were
to look through these electron
microscopes you know deep into a plant
or even your hand although it appears to
be solid
um we see vibrating packets of this
thing we call Energy vibrating pot
packets of something called quanta right
and so if everything is vibrating
then is it possible and this is a
dialogue right is it possible that when
you and I have a thought
a positive one a negative one a thought
about something we want or something we
don't want right so it's a thought a
spark of electrochemical activity in the
brain of thought we say you know I want
this I don't want that is it possible
let's just have a little dialogue here
is it possible that since that thought
is a burst of electrical activity and
also releases a chemical that correlates
with that thought is it possible
that
the electrochemical activity is
vibrating
oscillating moving whatever you want to
call it at a certain frequency
that resonates or repels with certain
things in the physical world is it
possible if everything is energy
um
how do you get into resonance with what
it is you want to you know attract how
do you get mentally physically
emotionally spiritually in resonance
with the stuff that you want instead of
what you don't want here's one of the
biggest challenges
our brains are wired for safety first
emotional safety physical safety
Financial safety first and so in order
to protect ourselves our brain actually
has to think about where is their danger
like where could I get hurt and in
thinking about where you can get hurt is
it possible that sometimes we're in a
temporary or permanent state of fear
and if we're in a permanent or temporary
state of fear is it possible that that
state of fear or uncertainty or
self-doubt is actually attracting
resonating with the stuff that we don't
want
one of the keys to applying the law of
resonance
is getting your mindset right the brain
right focused on what it is that you
want
getting your heart
right the emotions aligned as well so
it's head and heart aligned also with
what it is you want to resonate with
and then there's another piece to it
that not a lot of people think about or
talk about and that's the gut
right the brain gut access is in
communication with each other at all
times and there's a lot of research
around you've got to really follow your
instincts right your intuition your
instinctual feeling about stuff so you
got to get the head the heart and the
gut aligned and that is really the
winning combination to be in a state of
resonance when we stop expecting things
to be the way that we think they should
be when we stop forcing outcomes and
when we start allowing what is of the
highest good to be our only agenda our
only intention that's when the universe
truly has our back that's when we can
live what it means to surrender true
surrender comes when we stop praying for
what we think we need and we start
connecting and grounding in what could
possibly be of the highest good for all
and when we stop praying for what we
think we need and we start allowing what
is of the highest good for all so true
manifesting is about receiving what is
of the highest good for all and it
begins not just with what will how will
I get what is of the highest good but
how can I be open to what is of the
highest good how can I open up my
Consciousness to release what I think I
need and get grounded in what is
possible and what is of the highest good
not just for me and my agenda but the
highest good for all that's the message
so you're doing everything right and
that you're open to a spiritual practice
you're willing to grow you're showing up
for your practice you're reading books
you're doing the work you're here on
dear Gabby you're showing up you're
showing up you're showing up you're
doing a lot of doing though and you're
also doing a lot of expecting and so a
lot of doing and a lot of expecting are
two major blocks to your ability to
attract what it is that you want into
your life and so it's the doing doing
that actually creates sort of a manic
manifesting vibration which is how do I
get that what am I what do I do next got
to do this thing next gotta do this
thing next and that lacks the belief
system that I can be still and I can
allow
that's number one number two being in
the expectation of what you think things
should be is another block to your
manifesting power and your super
attractor power which is what I call it
because your expectations are limiting
the possibilities your expectations are
limiting the highest good as this card
says so when we start to pray for what
is of the highest good rather than
intend and pray for what we think we
need that's when the universe can
conspire with what it is that is of the
highest good for all so ultimately
what's happening is all the doing doing
is energetically blocking and all the
expecting expecting expecting is
blocking the manifestation as well
because when you're in this tunnel
vision of expectation it should be this
way it should be further along I
shouldn't be here what's happening is
you're missing the opportunity to
recognize where you are how great things
are in this moment what is possible In
This Moment the creative possibility In
This Moment the exciting potential In
This Moment you're blocking it blocking
it blocking it blocking it blocking it
blocking it
I want you to sit on your ass
I want you to stop doing doing doing
I want you to
start being being
which is what you also said you're
actually dear gabbing yourself you said
I want to embody the feeling I want to
embody the emotion
the being
is a presence it's an energy it's a
state
it's not an action
true manifesting does require us to show
up for our desires you've got to pick up
the phone and then call the job
interview and you have to ask for the
date and you have to to do whatever it
is that you want to create but
ultimately
the greatest source of power that we
have to attract what we want is how we
feel how do we reshape our self-image to
serve us as opposed to bring us down
well
it's interesting molts
Maxwell malts actually discovered
self-image as we know it today
he was a cosmetic surgeon and he found
if he operated on a person maybe they
had a distasteful scar in their face
and he removed the scar
he said
sometimes there was a phenomenal change
in the person's personality
but he said other times they'd remove
the scar who was very successful no
change in their personality
that led him to postulate that we not
only have this physical image that
reflects back from the mirror we have an
inner image of ourself
it's how we see ourselves right now that
inner image is an idea and that idea is
generally
planted in our little life when we're
infants
and it's planted by virtue of the the
environment that we're surrounded by
how we're raised if a child's raised
with praise they're going to grow up
very confident individuals if a child is
raised with criticism they're going to
grow up very insecure
so you see this image that we have it's
a picture of how we see ourself
but most of us
that image was planted by people it
didn't know what the hell was going on
they didn't know the war was over and
they were planting they were developing
a little mind it was a mind they were
shaping it like fresh clay they didn't
understand that it was a kid they're
looking after him we feed him we'd keep
them warm but the hell you know that's
our responsibility no it was a mind and
they were developing that mind and if
they didn't understand what were they
going to put in well they could give it
to the child is the insecurities that
they had themselves
so that was the picture that the kid
grows up of himself now I grew up very
insecure I was born during the
Depression when I first went to school
the second world war had just broken out
so everybody's rationed for everything
it was hard times all the men were away
fighting in Europe or South Pacific
there was no men doing nothing the women
that were there were driving the trucks
there were cops they did everything so
it wasn't a whole lot of time used for
developing a little mind
so I just grew up and picked up what I
could I got very insecure it wasn't
until I met a man that gave me this book
and gave me some damn good instruction
and I started to pay attention to who I
was
and I have never stopped being
fascinated with studying me yeah I I am
the most fascinating subject that I've
ever come across
and I have found out that you and I are
exactly the same we only appear to be
different
our physical body looks different we
choose different vocations some earns
more or less than the other
put our potential is exactly the same we
both live in a physical body
we both have these higher mental
faculties we're both Spiritual Beings we
both drawn in Infinite Source of supply
we're the same
so the trick I think for the person that
has insecurities that hasn't got the
strongest image they want they should
find a damn good Mentor
that's what changed my life there is a
reason many of the Great women and men
of the world the great history makers
the great poets the great philosophers
the great movement makers Rose before
the sun there is a magic in the air at
5am and that's why the 5am club is so
transformational because it's the time
of greatest quietude and I believe
Tranquility is the new luxury on our
planet it is that a time of intimate
creativity because you've just been
arrested your brain is fresh there's
there's latest there's there's very
recent Cutting Edge science coming out
now when you sleep your brain actually
has a mechanism to wash itself when you
wake up in the morning your willpower is
strongest when you wake up in the
morning you've got a full well of mental
focus and we know that focus in our
world is even more valuable than
intelligence and I could go on and on on
the benefits I mean you get up at 5am
you've got the world to yourself there's
no crowds you can think you can plan you
can care for yourself in a world where
so many people are so depleted and so
the five it the 5 a.m Club really is a
game changer and then it's not just get
up at 5am and you know scratch your
stomach or stare up at the ceiling or
look at your phone or look at especially
not I believe you can play with your
phone or change the world you don't get
to do both yeah and so uh it the 5am
club method is based on the 20 20
formula I'm happy to get into it but
that is tell us what it is that's the
revolutionizer and and it started from
my experience with working with many
billionaires I've I've coached many of
the most successful financiers and
Titans of industry for for over two
decades and one of the things I would
run them through is the way you begin
your day sets up the way you live your
day and so the 20 20 formula that the
book is based upon is pretty simple I I
go into great detail in the book but
essentially it's from five to five
twenty the first pocket is move and I'm
a fanatic about neuroscience and why do
you get up and move because you're going
to release serotonin which is going to
make you feel better you're going to
release dopamine which is the pleasure
and inspirational neurotransmitter
you're going to release norepinephrine
which will boost your focus you'll
promote neurogenesis Marie you can
actually grow new brain cells and
increase your metabolic rate so the way
you begin the way you feel when you
first wake up is not the way you're
going to feel at 5 20. Second pocket of
the 20 20 20 formula 20 minutes from 520
to 540 that's on reflection so a lot of
us are busy but what's the point of
being busy if you're doing the wrong
things the the billionaires the great
creatives the people of great impact the
people who live Beautiful lives are very
intentional they're very deliberate
they're very conscious so for 20 minutes
you write in a journal you can visualize
you can pray you can meditate you can
simply contemplate how you're going to
live your day what you want to stand for
during the day for example and then the
final pocket of the 22 2020 formula is
all about grow and that's where you you
just read from a biography or a business
book or philosophy book or a I watch a
marietv well especially
yeah of course that's the game changer
isn't it and so that's 20 minutes of
growing because I think we're most alive
when we are growing yes and um I believe
the leader who learns the most wins so
that's in a nutshell the 20 20 formula I
used to struggle a lot with manifesting
just the idea of it I would watch videos
on it and I didn't understand what they
were saying I didn't I just didn't
understand it uh with his manifest in a
lot of attractions like what are they
saying I don't understand the words that
are coming out of your mouth and I would
rewind and watch again it's like I don't
get it I don't understand I don't I
don't understand and it seemed weird
silly not good enough for me to just sit
on a couch and think about money coming
into your wallet or whatever it was that
you're trying to manifest you got to go
do something that in law of attraction
you know action is at the end of
Attraction like you got to go off and
and do the work if that's been you if
you've been kind of struggling with
manifesting or Law of Attraction you
don't know how it makes sense you rewind
videos and it feels too woo-woo for you
let me uh let me let me explain it from
a different perspective and and maybe
it'll help at least this is what's
helped me the first thing that I
realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems it's part of your
brain that decides what to pay attention
to and what to not pay attention to
there there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
cuddle of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
and it's too blurry you're still looking
at my face you're looking at my car
you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible to be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often
why that's your reticular activating
system basically saying I want to pay
attention to those things so that car
was still around right I mean I I got
this car we've got a Porsche and now I
see Porsches more often those Porsches
still existed they were they were
already there I just didn't notice them
before and now I notice them because I
have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention toward it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car new house or business growth or you
speaking on stage or whatever your goals
are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with
and as soon as I came up with an idea I
was like oh you can't do that or I had
to have the perfect Plan before I would
ever take any kind of action on it and
you know just later realize that
you can never plan all the way out
there's no way you know if you wait till
you have the perfect plan by the time
you start actually executing the plan is
is dead it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe the great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you shortcut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then but when when you're
positive and optimistic and bold and
courageous and an idea comes to you
trust that that's the right idea for you
just trust that it's already and then go
do something about it where normally
what we do is we overthink and we over
plan we over prepare and then we lose
the momentum and then the next day and
the next week or the next month it's
gone it's over it's like oh I can't do
that no that was actually a great idea
for you and it's happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically
but I just decide to listen to it and do
something on it and it leads to
something amazing
the amount of times that has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it
so number one reticular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car uh when you
buy your new car you see that car
everywhere and then number two is trust
a good ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that a lot of the
manifestation a lot of Attraction people
talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
uh that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or I'm
that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh 70 000 people you know
I am I am the author of a best-selling
book uh I am like whatever your goal is
and what I think the point of that is is
yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but I think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that and the more you
feel like it feels like to be that the
more it actually becomes true if your
goal is to speak on stage in front of 5
000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and there's 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something that
I would tell other people you know like
oh yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
because because it I haven't spoken at a
stadium that big but
to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
but look I've got I've got a belly here
I've got a you know whatever I'm I'm I
am healthy I am healthy and visualizing
yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like
manifestation law of attraction was way
out there stuff that that I judged and
that I didn't understand and that didn't
make any sense like just go off and take
action guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the biggest mindset shift that you need
to make check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there so when
you think a deliberate thought of what
you want then Law of Attraction will
employ the universe and all people
circumstances and events to move you